forgive me for this question what's the
stupidest way to write a screenplay
well you're talking to someone who's a
big fan of the outline so i would say
and not that the person who does it is
stupid
but those are my words not yours your
words my words
uh send the letters and cards yeah it'll
be um
they know the email it would be just to
sit down and say i got an idea
a half-baked idea that really wasn't
thought out
and you can do what you want which is
fine but i just think you know
and you may find there's a scene in
there that's great and brilliant but
a cohesive through line and all that it
takes time it takes
it takes work you know um
this isn't something that just spills
out
some people say i can just spill a
script out in in a week well that's
fantastic and and we'll see how good it
is and maybe you can do that
everybody's got their own way but uh
there are a lot of pitfalls in in that
in doing that you know with the story
and things aren't working and
it's just it's i hate when i sit there
and i write something and i know it's
just bad
i the best times and you know we all go
through that but the best times are
where
it's i'm it's like this weird uh
channeling and i can almost i can see it
in my mind's eye and that's going on to
the page
and i feel good about it because it's
like i watched
it i already watched it in the theater
but it hasn't existed yet except in my
head
going to so it's in a way when it's
really good it feels like you're
channeling it
and when it's bad there's something the
channel is not
those waves are not coming through not
to be like you know oh
you know you're all done you age yeah
dial up versus
sure your own you're you're tapping into
your your creative
um thing your well whatever you want to
call it where you go
and it's it's it's you know the signal's
not
and you just write down a scene you're
like that's going to have to be
rewritten
you know imagine now you probably
a person probably wouldn't think that
just burning through a script oh this is
great oh you know but
you when it's just bad and you're like
that oh my god it's garbage it's
terrible
like a placeholder instead of the real
scene you know yeah okay well
this is just this is the bad version as
everyone says
you know you get that note from people
say well um
here's the bad version and they tell you
it and you're like
that's really not that bad but you know
no no i don't want you to do that but
here's an example of what not to do
you know the bad version as as you hear
in hollywood a lot
and i'm like are you ever going to tell
me the good version and they said no
that's for you to figure out
i'm like oh you're right you're right
because i'm the writer right
throw me a lifeline here you know i'm
drowning
because i got the bad version that's the
real bad version is this sunset
boulevard
yeah exactly yeah
yeah is it almost similar to the people
that in college said i don't have to
study i just show up for tests
in a way and there's some that can i've
never met any
but um yeah i
especially especially with the i think
with the
um with the odds that there's so many
scripts out there
and so many good scripts too that
i think a lot of times writers don't
may not see the mountain that they're
climbing every day or what they're
you know you're not only up against your
own competing with yourself you know to
be a better writer
next time and next time and learn like
you should
uh but also what's actually out there if
you want to work in the marketplace type
of thing and i know when you say that
when i say that it sounds very
non-romantic
you know but it's a business
you know so why not put your best foot
forward in creating that
you know unless you have no um if you
have a good day job and there's no
pressure you know to that this script
has to sell
you know to make your rent or your
mortgage payment and you're just like
yeah i'll dabble in it
but dabbling takes time as well and so
you know while you're dabbling another
person is
working 24 hours a day and learning the
craft and really you know patch they
want it more than anything else
and uh it can be a hobby it's fine
you know but i think there are ways to
approach a career or a writing
career in a certain way and people can
try it
however they want but the
this you're back to your original
question is just to go i think i have an
idea
and not really whoa you know hold on a
second
you know what are you doing here with
this idea you know
every idea is a kernel of a premise that
builds now but do we have enough
is you know type of thing and that's a
second guess like what's selling if it's
really a passion idea you want to write
absolutely go you know you must do it
but you also um yeah
and what about people that say well
i don't want to write for tv or i don't
want to write a movie that
doesn't have a-list talent in it and
they they stomp on something
because it's not star wars sure
what do you say to that they want to be
a screenwriter they want to work in the
industry
but oh no that's not
that's not 48 hours or you know i'll
pick more there's some
movies sorry let me pick something in
the
last few decades um no i know what you
mean right okay it's not it's
but you're saying they stomp on the the
smaller ideas
yes i i read a lot of uh
scripts that are big big ideas
you know big hollywood ideas which is
fantastic
but the real odds of an unknown
uncredited writer it could happen it
does once in a great not as much as it
used to in the past you know
selling that thing that's the only thing
they've written
because intellectual property
ip is all the rage you know it's already
been a book it's been
you know a comic book it's been it's
been a sequel prequel
you know star wars is a perfect example
we just we just manufacture until the
end
and then we come up with a new series
right that's all done we'll veer off on
this one and we'll take that
character and we'll make a whole series
on that one
um that's a bigger that you're trying to
you're trying to hit a home run out of
the park
which we all do all the time but you're
i think you're also shrinking your your
possibility because
they already have the a-list writers out
there you know who are filling those
jobs
and how does how do they get there well
i don't know everybody has their own
journey
if you trace um i was saying a writer
uh who's a big tv person now and
features
started on xena princess warrior now
people would look down and go
xena that's a ridiculous uh you know
blah blah
everybody starts somewhere sure and was
it his heart's desire to
work on that show forever no but that
was a
stepping ground everybody has that
stepping ground you just don't
my experience and the people i've known
you just don't start out
at the top you know you take the job
and you go yeah okay it's not my perfect
thing but i'll
now i'll do it's a step-by-step process
so
um i would say in that way don't step on
those little ideas
because those are the ones that can be
made
you're taking a bigger gamble writing
this hundred million dollar script
that's locked into that budget
you know can't be made for less so then
you say well where can it
be made i know there's four studios that
could possibly do this
let's say they all pass were you gonna
go with the script
somebody's gonna shell out a hundred
million dollars of their own money i
mean you know what i mean
so the smaller idea
um smaller in scope meaning you know
we're not out to save the universe the
universe could be your own life
you know your your little universe uh
could actually be made
five million dollars two you know it's
not
it's not um glamorous like like a lot of
writer well i'll just sell my script for
millions of dollars and
and you think that your life changes
overnight you still have the same
problems
you still have the same relationship you
still have you're still a person it's
just
it's a job you know what i mean it's
sort of and i hate to sort of
shrink it down to that but but it's like
oh it's screenwriter yeah i used to
think the same way too in film school oh
my god
you know you read the trades you're like
oh he's i'm gonna live the life
live the life yeah you're gonna be
living the life at two in the morning
writing the screenplay that's what it is
it's work it's not glamor
there's times when uh you're forgotten
about at a screening
happened where they thank everybody yeah
bling bang
and then they thank the craft service
and then they go let's run the film
and you're sitting with the stars and
they look at you and you're mortified
you're like
and then afterwards of course it was it
was just a
it was an oversight and at the party it
was like oh my god i'm so sorry
have another martini you know i'll call
you yeah
well i wasn't that bad but it was just
you know what i mean it's not all going
to be
uh and if you're in it for that fame and
fortune and
fanfare not the writer
i mean we've made inroads a little more
than the past
but it's still you know you're still the
writer
i mean it sounds it's the most one of
the most important
people because that's where
without the scripts is they say there's
nothing right but
you know that's why you should like try
to be a hyphenate writer producer
you know writer director or something
like that eventually i mean
or start out as that that's your that's
your choice
you know that's your career direction
but just the writer
it's you know it's an interesting road
you